El peor escenario posible:
apocalipsis zombi.
¿Cómo sobrevivirás?
Tal vez te sorprenda descubrir
lo mucho que la geografía
te puede ayudar a evitar el fin.
Cuando me refiero a la geografía, quiero
decir analizar el mundo a tu alrededor.
Un concepto geográfico
que te podría ayudar mucho
en un apocalipsis zombi
es el movimiento migratorio.
Así que primero, ¿qué emigra?
Las personas se trasladan,
Los animales se trasladan
y, aunque a veces muy lentamente,
los zombis también se trasladan.
Pero eso no es todo.
La mercancía se traslada también.
La mercancía puede ser recursos,
como reservas de alimentos
y de armas.
Estos recursos normalmente los trasladan
las personas o los zombis.
Así, si ves un montón
de reservas para zombis
donde antes no había,
es probable que vayas
por buen camino.
Las ideas también se trasladan.
Las ideas pueden
incluir entretenimiento,
películas de zombis.
noticias e información
sobre ataques de zombis,
y la arquitectura,
o cómo construir un refugio seguro.
Y, segundo, ¿por qué se trasladan
las personas o los zombis?
Cuando las personas, los animales
o los zombis se trasladan,
se llama "migración".
Dos conceptos que
afectan a la migración
son factores de
repulsión y de atracción.
Los factores de repulsión
harán que quieras irte de un sitio.
Los factores de atracción
hacen que quieras a un sitio.
Una falta de recursos,
una economía poco estable,
o un alto índice de delincuencia
pueden ser factores de repulsión que hagan
que la gente quiera migrar.
El buen clima,
una buena economía
o muchos recursos
podrían ser factores de
atracción para mucha gente
persuadiéndola a trasladarse.
Mientras los zombis son ciertamente
un factor de repulsión para los humanos,
una ciudad llena de gente sería
un factor de atracción para
zombis hambrientos que
quieren comer humanos.
Hay algunas cosas
que hacen el traslado
más fácil para las personas o los zombis.
Canales y carreteras hacen
más rápido el viajar.
Trasladarse a través de
un espacio despejado y abierto
es más fácil que un terreno agreste.
E igual que la tierra
puede crear fronteras
que afectan a la migración,
también pueden crearlo
las fronteras políticas,
como por ejemplo,
la verja de una frontera.
Así, ¿cómo puedes analizar
estos factores de migración
para que te ayuden a sobrevivir?
Hay tres pasos básicos.
Primero: identificar los puntos
o lugares para analizar.
¿Cuáles son tus opciones?
Segundo: buscar
lo que los conecta.
¿Hay carreteras, canales
o terreno abierto?
Y tercero: buscar los
patrones de traslado
que suceden en esa conexión.
¿Se trasladan las personas o
la mercancía a través de ella?
Cuando comparamos la relación
entre distintos lugares,
podemos ver las conexiones que tienen.
Por ejemplo, elige dos ciudades.
Mira la carretera que las conecta.
Si la gente utiliza esa carretera
para viajar diariamente al trabajo,
esas ciudades tienen una relación fuerte.
Pero esta otra ciudad por aquí
no tiene una conexión
directa con las otras ciudades.
Incluso hay un río en el camino.
No tiene una relación tan fuerte.
Si un brote de zombis empezara aquí,
¿en qué ciudad preferirías estar?
¿A dónde huirías?
Entonces, ¿cómo decides a dónde
ir en un apocalipsis zombi?
¿Simplemente corres
en una dirección arbitraria?
O ¿utilizas tus capacidades geograficas
para guiar a tu grupo de
supervivientes a un lugar seguro?
Si quieres seguir vivo,
ayuda entender el cómo y
el porqué nos trasladamos.